hello and welcome to three scary games
[Music]
a boo
look see did you jump scare him
ah yeah they
you didn't
oh
i didn't give you enough of a setup all
right i'll give you some more okay all
right i'll give you something good i
promise i promise i won't let you down
i never do
never do
hi
yeah
no
okay all right all right i'll do one
more but this is the last time okay i'll
real i'm gonna give it my all i'm gonna
give it my all i'm gonna give it my all
okay cool
this is dog house two
that dog is not dead i don't know how to
stress that the dog is fine and alive
and we're gonna build that dog in dog
house and this is dog house too i've
never even played dog house one but
apparently this is multiple endings
eagle vision okay sounds good
sounds good sounds good
oh that's big dog
oh leonard i will build you a home soon
all right leonard you got it
instructions on building a doghouse
quite lengthy
all right tree do i need wood
i can't open it from the outside
all right
that's probably fine
that's probably totally fine
oh leonard i'm gonna whoa
what
i need to unlock the garage to get
started i need to address my artistic
choices my sense of style needs work
that's what it needs
some abg blocks whatever you happen to
see i don't know i don't know whatever
happened to uh
good art choices weirdly works with cds
too my final how to get away with doing
nothing
oh my god
what is wrong with me oh spaghetti a
piece by jam from an art market yeah
don't go there anymore kind of creeps me
out to be honest yeah why did you buy it
why is this knocked over why is that
blocked off
what is with this
the majestic king panda no it's not
that's not what this is anyway
turn that off save some power knife
please i keep this around for
self-defense and you know
cooking
in the event of a lettuce attack oh i'm
i'm a comedian here all right sure ooh
leonard's favorite song
all right
pick it up and play it for him when he's
upset why would he be upset
how deadly is his upset i should take a
bite to see if it's done
good
stuff
what
oh
i'll go on stage please that's where i
belong okay anyway
now for our main event please welcome
leonard leonard
hello everyone
great to be here
what's the deal with fire hazards in my
right
everything's fine must have been a weird
dream good lasagna though
can i have another bite
nope okay just save that for leonard i
guess
ah my garage i need to open the garage
first okay
hi leonard
how you doing buddy
hey
hey poopy
okay oh
leonard
lunard
how do i get out of my home
i seem to have fenced myself in i'm not
very good at building things
and now the hammer
hi
okay
this is fine
looking good is it
is it
is that my oven beeping
god it better not be
did i forget to turn it off
not quite done
what do you mean not quite done i took a
bite of that
of course it was done it was done a
while ago why my lights go off
who did this to me
how dare you
me do that
oh
i need to hurry up and build this thing
um
okay
no
any second now any second now what
what's gonna happen any second now whoa
hi puppy
oh what
oh okay
that's a good pop
that oh you humanely captured leonard
inside the doghouse the next day you
decided to call law enforcement by by
the time they arrived they found the dog
house was empty you still wonder where
he could have gone good ending i did it
i guess what
whoa
hey what's up pooch
hey what's up gang i'm gonna go
do this
yoink hey what's up
hey there poochie
um
uh
i need to get the nails okay i don't
exactly know where i
made a choice there
and now the ham are
looking good
oven
who turned my lights off
stop it oh mentos
a bucket of mints i keep
sure
okay
stop
oh
oh hey what's up pup lenny
[Music]
leonard you all right
oh hey that's okay oh unfinished
business your once beloved pet is now
something of a different breed he tried
to escape him but died in the process
[Music]
oh i need to hurry up and build it oh
how why what
no what huh
i wha
[Music]
all right there's there must be
something else to do here i imagine it
has to do with something like crouching
or whatever
because it told me that i could crouch
better kept inside would especially
after last time what does that mean what
do you mean
better kept inside what's better kept
inside what do you mean better kept
inside there might be something about
crawling into here and hiding what if i
hide no i can't get in there i might be
able to hide from him when he's
attacking me you know what i mean i
might be able to
okay oh bean
no
lights go off
i come here
[Music]
okay hey pups uh what if i ah maybe this
will calm him down it will
i should go now i should go now i should
go now get him get him
oh
[Music]
okay
do i turn the lights
now
okay
you wanted you want to dance with me
you want to dance together
ooh disco you were able to soothe the
savage beast
you decided to make the most of the
situation and entered into a dog dancing
contest where you and leonard went on to
receive many accolades
oh
i know what else to do i don't know if i
want to do it though
oh
come at me bro come at me bro
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do huh what are
you gonna do
hey stab stab sap oh oh come on
okay i don't know the other endings and
i don't have the patience to find them
but not bad
had some like subtly spooky things there
to it but not overtly scary i would say
but not bad you know not bad not
bad
moving on
this is uh experiment grocery store i
think was it called
and it's something about you working in
a grocery store which is already a
horrifying experience as we've already
established from other games
hello cinematic
wow
nice ride
could you drive slower grandma
you know we some of us got places to be
let's uh
pick up the pace a little bit you know
mosey along you know let's uh
no take your time
oh shopping okay here we go
cola pizza taco
the three main food groups really my
priorities as a
human being or this is not a door i am
incredibly stupid hey
i'll be right there be right there
hey hey hey
how you doing
i'm looking for a pizza cola taco
you have pizza cola taco here your neck
is so flexible
pizza cola taco
just point me in the general direction
and i'll head on over there
don't you squint your eyes at me don't
do that
it's cool talking all right i'll help
myself cola that's helpful
one
thanks thank you poppa right in the bag
there i'll pay for it as soon as i found
the pizza taco
okay bye
um ice cream no
you got any pizza pizza by the slice
ah
this is some good stuff you know this is
quality
when uh
reducing plastic i see anyway
taco single doughnut on a shelf
condiments
hamburgers
taco ah here we go
oh i need more cola how much more cola
could i possibly need anyway i got a
taco one's good for me
just the one please how about a green
how about oh canned food oops guy cola
you got any coal coal of course
yeah
no oh there we go oh i see i see i see
okay thank you
i'll take this thank you
anyway you having a good night slow
round here you know
supply chain issues and all that
all right i'll be gone
thanks
two bags huh
reduce all that plastic and then give me
two plastic bags don't squint your eyes
at me all right bye
guess i'm all done
gotta get my ass home to my exciting
life
get some pizza in me maybe a taco or two
or one i only buy one
all right that was great
but
what
beer doughnut pete what is this the same
night did i just go oh okay hey hey hey
look who's back it's me
your favorite customer
man you need to get the janitor in here
anyway looking for some beer donut pizza
all right anyway i'll help myself thank
you very much yeah
don't excuse me
popper on there
come back for another pizza that's first
slice was just too good couldn't pass up
another opportunity to get some za in me
you know what i mean
anyway where's the beer
don't squint your eyes at me where's the
beer i'll find it myself don't worry
with the other drinks probably
now here we go
the old devil's sauce as they call it i
call it that you don't have to call it
that
so uh
you from around here
all right see you around i'll be back
wink wink wink you know me
always in the neighborhood
always having a good time i'll see you
around
donut sauce taco
okay
oh i have a flashlight that's
interesting hey hey hey guess who's back
it's me again now i'm just gonna be on
my way i won't bother you seems like
your cake sign is a little droopy
you like my flashlight i just found it
pretty cool right almost makes you want
to squint your eyes because it's so
bright there you go
all right
uh donut sauce taco
well no more pizza i guess
[Music]
my sauce i prefer the yellow myself
another taco
i'll hold myself to it
just the one no okay last one hey lucky
me must be my lucky day
uh who knows what else good could happen
today you know what i'm saying
anything
could uh
maybe win the lottery
anyway
see ya
around
just hungry tonight you know just gotta
buy a lot of stuff guess who's back it's
uh
me
hey
okay all right you
you squinting your eyes at me oh my god
oh my god hi you know i wanted to talk
to you before but for some reason i
don't really want to now
is that your
beard are you just happy to see me ma'am
you good you good ma'am
no okay all right what's my list i don't
even have you know what i forgot what my
list was i
think i'm gonna go i think i'm gonna go
i think i'm gonna well
okay my instinct was right off the bat
if you could stop winking at me that'd
be great i'm gonna just
find another way out
i don't like that sound
well i didn't even know you had
bathrooms in here
just gonna check all the stalls for some
damn reason
all right all right okay all right here
apparently oh
this is an impressive server that you've
got here why
hey
how you doing pal oh wow
nice teeth
uh
okay markiplier haven't noticed any
paranormal phenomenons yet human
unemployed single has a driver's license
discovered during the experiment
favorite products beer pizza donuts has
bought unprescribed unprecedented prizes
has not used the toilet brought 11
products in toil
oh
ma'am
uh
oh
ma'am
[Music]
oh
hey pal you all right okay i bet i guess
not okay
all right just gonna what is this
site 23 employee guidelines keep track
of the test subject at all times server
room must not be visited by regular
staff team restricted from leaving the
site during an experiment phase you must
comply with your supervisor's commands a
violation of these rooms will get you
extra toilet
why do you
why do you keep saying toilet
[Music]
that's not in my file i don't go to the
toilet
i'm gonna go to the toilet now
i'm going to go to this toilet
turlet
anybody turn it turl it
curl it throw it
throw it
urinate
i'm too scared to pee you god damn right
i am
what push
oh
oh this way ah
i see i see i see
i see okay i'm free
definitely 100
i am 100 free
[Music]
hi
hello
oh my god
i did it did i win am i free
oh god the end
i did it
oh
okay that was cool like legitimately it
was very cool and also the idea that it
was tracking what i did i don't know if
there are other endings if you do
different things that was really cool
though i like that a lot if you guys
want to check that out for yourself link
is in the description as always well as
most of the time unless i forgot but
check out if there's other endings to
that because that was very cool that was
very cool
but anyway moving on
this is after school by sir certo
edister
the caption of this one was where did
everybody go
so i'm guessing that i'm going to be at
school and no one else is going to be
here
hello
hi
all right
well i see an exclamation point
man my feet are slappy
where did everybody
go seems to not be anybody here
let leave
i'm done
what
don't tell me this is like scp-087b
please don't be scp-087b
okay
oh my god
oh no
oh
[Music]
hey this is definitely an scp thing
there's definitely an scp thing
what are you doing to me guys
what are you doing to me
well
i should probably go back
i should go back up at this point oh i
should go back
up oh [ __ ] stark
oh where did i go down
i knew what it was and yet i went down
anyway i must be some kind of idiot
i must be some kind of stupid
i must be some kind of dumb
been playing horror games for near on 10
years and i still don't know when not to
go into place
okay
well my ability to run has been severely
hampered
seems like i am not going to be going
anywhere anytime soon boy i should start
going back up at some point i haven't
even tried
what is that other son there's another
sound rising in the mix there's another
sound
something rising up
i don't like crescendos crescendos in
horror games means bad
it never means good it's always what was
that
what did i hear
oh
oh okay
all right fine then this is how you want
to play the game
am i getting slower i feel like i'm
getting slower
and up i go
dude i'm fast as hell boy
[Music]
oh my god you're still there okay don't
look back i'm looking back and uh
it seems if i run kind of crissy crossy
i go a little faster
oh yeah
serpentine here here yes no no yes no
i don't know this way
what what do you want
oh my god what no not like this
okay
i'm definitely safe 100 nothing bad is
gonna happen to me
you're a tall one
wait is that you
uh
well
this is
awkward oh my god
no students of the school was ever seen
again
nobody knows where they
went oh hi you weren't there before
what
what does that say is that a code what
no way wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
e might be an a a u
0 p e y r q let's try that first
let's try e
oh is that a v is that not a u is that a
v
okay it's definitely 0pyrq i think
that's a u
it doesn't seem like it's there anymore
or i'm not typing it right but that is
definitely a code let me check on their
page found the password which led to
some other stuff not sure if there was
more or not but i really enjoyed it wait
did did this guy and his video find the
password hang on pastebin.com
oh it's so hard to see it hey
maybe we should a it's not an e it's an
a
okay
ah
it's got a password to it so somewhere
in this game there's a password okay i
didn't look that up i looked up this
because i needed confirmation of what
this was that sounds different so
somewhere in here there's a password i
just got to find out where
maybe there's other oh i can't go this
way
what are you trying to hide something
from me
what are you trying to whoa is that a
note on the door
is that a note on the door no
fluked and returned
well that doesn't seem like a password
two point three three
two three three they're all two three
three
well i'll play through one more time but
if i'm not gonna get anything from this
then wait what was what's with the dawn
let me out
oh i gotta do this again
whoa
i saw that what the hell was that about
[Music]
i didn't like that i swear i didn't see
that before
what in the hell
imma where are you
where are you where not they're not
there okay gotcha got you guys gotcha
not today not today i'm fast as [ __ ] boy
okay somewhere here
i'm just willing to bet
it probably appeared afterwards right
that's what happened definitely
definitely definitely somewhere here
somewhere there
password
oh damn it
all right whoa whoa oh oh oh on the wall
there okay okay okay okay
all right okay okay
i saw it on the wall there i couldn't
get to it though but it was on the wall
i don't know why i only saw it then and
not before
but i saw it
just open the door hi hi it's me well
i'm out
bye
what are you doing oh my god
all right it's cool okay okay okay okay
okay
here oh it was there
what do you mean
what do you mean why wouldn't it be
there anymore i could i literally
couldn't get to it before like there was
no way to walk down there oh damn it
okay well that's dumb unless i gotta
like come here first and then go down
and then it would appear
no all right well i don't know i'm not
gonna be able to read it so i'm gonna
piggyback off of uh jar red
jar red
jared i think there's a code at the
bottom
you see it
was that there before it was there but i
couldn't read it i can
paste it and blow it up here and
two three one two three four i swear the
last two numbers are fours but it i mean
who the heck knows they might be nines
for all i know they definitely look like
fours okay so i spent a hell of a long
time trying to figure out the code i
thought it was zero zero zero zero zero
four four
it is in fact the letter d
five times and the number forty four and
this is what it unlocked
they are locked
and what looks like a string of binary
but i put the binary into a text
converter and this is what comes up
they are hidden in the d path find them
and bring them to me i think is what
it's trying to say but there are some
numbers hidden within this text seven
one two six one zero but i don't know
what that means that was it okay it was
it it was triple capital d and that
leads here so binary to text
they are hidden i think it means in the
depth find them and bring
them
to me
which there's no space there so if
you're gonna put this like that you
would be consistent about it so seven
one two six one zero might be a code but
this is a in the depth because in the
depth of the staircase that you went
down i don't think it means in this one
because it seems like the developer said
something along the lines of message
will help you in a future game of mine
be prepared and it's like okay well
that's fine i did not go through all the
work but thank you to jar red for doing
all the work well done you are more
persistent than i am because i gave up
on the previous one just get two endings
and i'll leave it to you
well i mean it's nothing really to leave
it to you except for those endings so
thank you for doing that but anyway this
was good not sure what the benefit of
finding the hidden stuff is if it's for
a future game but it's it's very good
very good
[Music]
that'll do it for this episode of three
scary games let's see and i got it this
time i got it i know what's going to
scare them i know it's going to scare
the pants off of them i'll tell you yeah
i'll take it and then you take it from
there and you've added a one-two punch
boom boom
we'll get it okay cool all right
[Music]